let's bring in Adam Schefter from the
mothership Adam will be on ESPN's NFL
live today at 1:30 eastern part of both
postseason NFL countdown shows on
Saturday and Sunday this weekend for the
divisional round as we welcome in the
Michigan grad Adam Schefter Adam thanks
for joining us
do we have any updates on the jobs that
are still open in the NFL yeah we've got
Miami and we've got Cincinnati and
neither team seems to be in any kind of
rush which tells you that they're
involved and some of the coaches
involved in the playoffs still which is
fine
Eric the enemy is still out there as the
Chiefs offensive coordinator Brian
floors is still out there
the Patriots defensive coordinator Zach
Taylor still out there as the Rams
quarterbacks coach Shane Waldron as the
Rams passing game coordinator so there
are still some coaches here in the
playoffs that these teams have spoken to
I looked at those would be obviously
interesting names although I think they
also are drawn to some other names
you've heard the name Todd Monken still
in play you've heard the name bands
Joseph still in play so we'll see what
these last year teams decided to do but
I will say this then we're six tire
rings in not one minority head coach yet
there were five minority head coaches
let go this offseason Meza was not added
one in its place so far more surprising
Kingsbury with the Cardinals or Lafleur
with the Packers Lafleur the Packers was
more surprising because the Arizona
Cardinals coveted Kliff Kingsbury all
along and the only question was whether
he was going to be able to get out of
his USC commitment whatever commitment
that was or was it and once he was
interviewing he was getting a job he
just that was the way it was going to be
they were looking for somebody exactly
like the guy and coach at Kliff
Kingsbury is now Lafleur when we
discussed head coaching candidates for
whatever that's worth was not discussed
as this frontline candidate which
doesn't mean he's not going to be a
great a coach when the right guy for the
Green Bay Packers
it's just that people weren't expecting
him to get and I know people are
surprised at Kliff Kingsbury got one is
a fired head coach of Texas Tech but
here's a god
gone out and work with Johnny Manziel
and work with packs with my homes and
working with some really good
quarterbacks whereas Matloff or you just
hear a lot of conversation about again I
think it comes back to the Shawn McVeigh
effect everybody wants the kind of cokes
and Shawn McVeigh has turned out to be
in Los Angeles and there are defensive
coaches around the league that are
taking notice about this that are
disillusioned by this but Matt Lafleur
worked out in LA he's got a bright young
offense of mind intelligence and so to
me it's a little bit more surprising
that he got hired but I understand the
question why are we looking for the next
Doug Peterson or Frank Reich why are we
looking for the next Shawn McVeigh well
maybe somebody like Vic Fangio is that
it seems like teams are more hesitant to
go get an experienced coach because
everybody wants the next best thing and
the flavor of the month and whoever's
hot and sexy at that particular moment
and sometimes the best coaches are the
most seasoned and experienced coaches
guys and haven't been given a chance
guys that have been waiting their life
to do it don't pee this is proven that
Frank Reich has proven that that what
there's nothing wrong with the Andy Reid
effect right all you guys that he's
produced from this tree I'm also curious
with what's going on with Josh McDaniels
that he took his name out of the running
or consideration for a head coaching job
it feels like when he didn't get the
Packers job all of a sudden he wasn't
interested in seeking another head
coaching job is that how this played out
there are eight jobs okay and we could
break it down on a case by case basis
right but he's not going to Denver okay
where they already fired him Josh isn't
going to take a job in Cincinnati or
Arizona no disrespect to his franchises
but coaches that have been out there who
have been selective aren't choosing
those franchises when they've been to
select him they've been okay he's not
going to Miami in the division we're now
down order de jets for that matter so
we're now down to the Green Bay Packers
the Cleveland Browns we didn't interview
it and I'm missing one
this progression of head coaching
vacancies but really knowing job that he
was in play for through his choice as
much as other teams choices was the
Green Bay Packers they hired somebody so
of course he added a search yeah right
Josh McHale is gonna be a coach josh
mcdaniels is gonna be a head coach at
some point in time
he just is and it's not going to be this
year so when he says yeah I'm not going
to be I'm taking my name out of the
running I don't want to be a head coach
as well tell me where there was going to
be a potential match there wasn't yeah
obviously surprised that he didn't get
the Green Bay job with all that
experience in LeFleur yeah came out of
nowhere
what is the general consensus of Kyler
Murray's talent level NFL wise and what
his future in the NFL is going to be or
could be this is going to be one of the
great topics leading up to the NFL dress
because you're talking about a guy who
was listed at I believe five nine not
that there's anything wrong with that
and you had a situation where a guy who
has tremendous probability who was the
most productive high school football
player ever to come out of the state of
Texas and that's a long list of players
with a lot of great talent you're
talking about
Drew Brees and Angela rock and all adult
and make foals nobody was better in
calimary and let me see this I believe
he unequivocally loves football more
than he loves baseball four years ago to
now everything circles back to his love
of football this year it was a test
drive to see if he could be great in
football against great competition they
proved himself I went in the Heisman
they can play with the best of them and
I think now that he's proven that I
think he wants to take his talents to
the next level and I know he'd have to
get back to four point six six million
dollars two days but he was going to go
and address higher than that and make
more money than that and if he turns out
to be the quarterback that some NFL
evaluator stinky will be closed next
contract an NFL quarterback is gonna be
225 million 39 35 million so there's
more money to be made in football
more important that I think he loves
football and wants to be a football
player but do you think he's gonna go
into the draft and he'd be a first-round
pick hey I know that you got a busy day
we appreciate you squeezing some time in
for us Thank You Adam you too Adam
Schefter
for the mothership there for more Dan
Patrick show to the audience Channel 239
on DirecTV or download the Dan Patrick
show app
[Music]